En 1991 y tras varios años de tiras y aflojas y mucha tensión, los países bálticos,
Lituania, Letonia y Estonia lograron
por fin romper con la Unión Soviética. De una vez por todas alcanzaron la libertad.
Habian pasado 50 largos años desde que los
soldados del ejército rojo ocupasen sus países.
Durante todo ese tiempo la represión y el
miedo fueron los ingredientes básicos en
la vida de los estonios, letones y lituanos.
Atentos a los datos. Tan sólo en Lituania,
un país de poco más de 2 millones y medio
de habitantes la ocupación soviética dejó
tras de sí estos números:
200.000 fueron personas arrestadas, interrogadas
y encarceladas.
132.000 personas deportadas, especialmente
a Siberia.
y 75.000 prisioneros, deportados y partisanos
fueron eliminados por el régimen soviético.
Y por si fuese poco, en el momento de su independencia,
la miseria y la escasez eran un ingrediente
básico en el día a día de todos sus habitantes
Desde entonces, amigos, las cosas han cambiado
mucho, muchísimo. Desde que estos países
recobraron la independencia apostaron decididamente
por la democracia y la libertad.
Hoy sus economías se sitúan entre las más
libres del mundo, son miembros de la Unión
Europea y de la OTAN, cuentan con niveles
de vida bastante altos, son muy prósperos,
están saneados y a todas luces ya los podemos
considerar como países ricos.
Es decir, el cambio, de los llamados tigres
bálticos ha sido brutal.
Incluso cuando en 2009 sufrieron mucho la
crisis internacional y sus economías parecieron
venirse abajo con caídas, ojo, de hasta
el 20% del PIB; frente a todos los pronósticos, en
muy poco tiempo consiguieron recuperarse y convertirse en todo un ejemplo para países
como España, Grecia o Portugal.
Pero de todo esto, amigos, hablaremos en otro
vídeo. En este nos vamos a ocupar de un grave
problema compartido por casi todos los países
de Europa del Este y que hoy por hoy supone
uno de las amenazas más importantes para
su futuro.
Para conocer mejor los países bálticos,
analizar de primera mano la transformación
que han tenido y también los problemas
a los que aún se enfrentan, especialmente
en el caso de Lituania, luego veréis por
qué, me he venido hasta aquí.
Y la verdad, amigos, os doy mi palabra de
que mi experiencia avala los datos.
El cambio de estos países está siendo sencillamente
increíble.
La historia de Lituania, así como la de las
repúblicas bálticas en general, es una historia
de éxito. Desde que en 1991 recobraron la
libertad estos países se han transformado
muchísimo, solo hay que venir para verlo.
Hoy son países modernos, con economías prósperas
y muy abiertos al comercio. ¡Bien hecho!
Como en toda buena historia, no todo siempre
es bonito. Y sí, hay problemas, también
en Lituania. En este caso el problema es la
fuga de cerebros, la emigración. ¡Sí, emigracion
con “e”!
Y, ojo, que el problema no es precisamente
pequeño. Tan solo desde que el país ingresó
en la Unión Europea, en 2004, Lituania ha
perdido más del 10% de su población.
Es decir, más de 300.000 personas, sobre todo
jóvenes, han hecho las maletas y se han trasladado
a otro país. Por cierto, casi la mitad de
todos ellos se han marchado al Reino Unido.
Sí, mientras que en Europa occidental y en
Estados Unidos hay un sentimiento digamos
de preocupación por la inmigración, aquí
en Lituania es al revés, están bastante
preocupados por la gente que se marcha. Y
es que aquí en Lituania la preocupación
es que esto termine por descapitalizar el
país”.
Y como siempre, entre los que se marchan están
los jóvenes con más capacidades, los mejores
formados, y por supuesto esto tiene un efecto
claro en la economía: la mano de obra más
joven disminuye, el talento se escapa, y la
población se envejece. Y ojo porque esto
no es un problema solo de Lituania, es algo generalizado en Europa del Este. Un dato muy
importante: desde 1990 son ya 20 millones
de personas las que han decidido marcharse.
¿Y quienes creeis que son los ganadores
de toda esta redistribución del talento?
Sí, así es, los países más ricos… Por
eso hay que tener mucho cuidado con determinados
mensajes que tratan de ganar votos convirtiendo
a la inmigración por sí misma en un enemigo
a batir. Sí, estamos pensando en personajes
como Theresa May o Donald Trump.
Pero… se lo que estás pensado ¿Si los
bálticos han tenido tanto éxito porque la
gente se va? Pues precisamente por eso, por
su éxito. Así, como lo escucháis.
Pues bien, por un lado estos países han
conseguido que, en general, la gente joven esté
bien formada y sepa hablar inglés, dos requisitos
muy importantes a la hora de buscar fortuna
en otros lugares.
Por otro lado, gracias al crecimiento que
han experimentado ahora tienen el dinero para
marcharse de una forma relativamente cómoda.
Pero… claro, nos queda una pregunta clave
¿Por qué se marchan si aparentemente el
país va tan bien? Pues… no es difícil
de explicar. Aunque los salarios han mejorado
mucho en los últimos años
la diferencia con los países más ricos sigue
siendo bastante grande. Por ejemplo, mientras
que el salario medio en Lituania es de 800€,
en Reino Unido es de casi 2.500€, tres veces
más.
Y entonces, ¿qué está ocurriendo? ¿A caso
ha sido todo este proceso de transformación
negativo para el país? Para nada, siempre
hay desajustes, ahora lo que deben preguntarse
es, ¿qué supone todo esto? y ¿cómo impedir
esa fuga de cerebros?
Acabar con los grandes flujos de emigración
y frenar la fuga de talento se ha convertido
en toda una prioridad en los países de Europa
del Este.
Algunos como Polonia, Letonia o Hungría han
puesto en marcha campañas de retorno con
las que tratan de convencer a los emigrantes
de que vuelvan a casa
Sin embargo, sin lugar dudas, es aquí en
Lituania donde más preocupación está generando
esta fuga de cerebros y donde mayor ha sido
la reacción de la sociedad.
En las últimas elecciones parlamentarias
que se celebraron en Octubre de 2016, un peculiar
partido conocido como la Unión de los Campesinos
y Verdes Lituanos, que solo tenía un diputado
en la legislatura anterior, fue el vencedor
y se hizo con el gobierno. Su principal promesa:
poner fin a la sangría de la emigración.
Pero claro, amigos, esto es algo que es muy
fácil de decir, pero no parece tan fácil
de llevar a cabo. Así que la pregunta es
¿Cómo quiere lograr semejante meta este
peculiar partido que está presidido, por
cierto, por Ramunas Karbauskis uno de los
empresarios más importantes del país?
Pues bien, según dicen su prioridad número
uno para frenar la emigración pasa por atraer
mucha más inversión extranjera. Según afirman
si consiguen que llegue a Lituania mucho más
dinero del extranjero para invertir, lograran
que haya más empleos, que mejoren los tipos
de trabajo y que suban los salarios.
¿Pero cómo quieren conseguirlo?
Para lograr atraer más inversión extranjera,
el nuevo gobierno ha prometido reducir la
burocracia, perseguir férreamente la corrupción
e introducir aún más flexibilidad en el
mercado laboral. Es decir, aparentemente parece que el nuevo gobierno no quiere cambiar
los ingredientes de la fórmula báltica de
éxito.
Y la verdad, todo esto suena bastante bien,
tiene mucho sentido. Casi podríamos decir
que una vez más, parece que en los países
bálticos saben hacer muy bien las cosas.
Pero… esperad un segundo… porque aquí
no acaba toda la historia. Hay algunas cosas
que… como decirlo… no resultan tan bonitas.
Por una lado, al mismo tiempo que el gobierno
habla de inversión extranjera también se
ha comprometido a subir impuestos eliminando
lo que se conoce como Flat-Tax.
Fijaos, En Lituania, y también en Estonia
y Letonia, los sistemas fiscales son muy sencillos.
En el caso de Lituania existe un flat tax,
una tarifa plana de impuestos, tanto para empresas
como para personas del 15%. Es decir, el que gana
10.000€ paga 1.500€ y el que gana diez veces
más, 100.000€, paga también 10 veces más
impuestos, en este caso 15.000€.
Pues bien, más allá de otras cuestiones
no parece que la mejor forma de atraer más
inversión extranjera y hacer subir los salarios
sea elevar los impuestos. Que por cierto,
para las empresas, no son tan bajos como parecen.
Si tenemos en cuenta los pagos a la Seguridad
Social y otras tasas e impuestos, según el
Banco Mundial las empresas en Lituania pagan
algo más del 40% de su beneficio bruto en
impuestos.
Por otro lado está el tema de Rusia y la
OTAN. Los últimos gobierno de Lituania y
este no es una excepción, se han empeñado
en trasladar a su población y también al
mundo que hay una amenaza cierta de invasión
rusa, que el país está en peligro.
Vale, es verdad, lo hemos visto en VisualPolitik,
amenazas existen, pero ¿Creeis que esta es
la mejor forma de trasladar confianza a los
inversores?
Y por último y tal vez lo más importante,
una cuestión tal vez de corte cultural que
afecta a todo el país. Si hay fuga de talento
parecería lógico tratar de suplir está
pérdida atrayendo profesionales y a jóvenes
de otros países...
¿No os parece?
Sin embargo, amigos, también aquí existe,
cierto recelo hacia la inmigración. Los países
bálticos son un pelin nacionalistas…
En fin, de todas formas, si algo está claro,
es que tanto Lituania como Estonia y Letonia
han hecho muy bien las cosas y que sus políticas
parecen bastante mejores que las que abundan
en el resto de Europa.
En apenas 25 años han conseguido convertirse
en países ricos con niveles de vida bastante
altos. Si no me creeis os aconsejo un viaje
por estos países. Os prometo que además
de disfrutar muchísimo vais a sorprenderos
con todo lo que han conseguido en tan poco
tiempo.
Bueno turno, para ti. ¿Creés que conseguirán
las repúblicas bálticas frenar esta ola
emigratoria? Esperamos tu respuesta y como
siempre, si te ha gustado el vídeo, no te
olvides de darle al botón de like. ¡Un saludo,
y hasta la próxima!